hi there I'm Freddie Highmore and today
I'm doing a wired autocomplete interview
I just get rid of this throw over my how
is Freddie Highmore and doing well thank
you
how did Freddie Highmore get famous well
there's a assumption in the question I'm
not really sure I am I don't have the
you know the social media or the Twitter
or Instagram so I'm not not famous
according to in today's way of judging
it how talk is Freddie Highmore how talk
is he sounds like some American slang
that I don't know what that means or how
tall I'm this tall tall 510 511 how did
Freddie Highmore die it was a very sad
day but I decided to come back purely to
do these questions thank you for
reviving me how old is Freddie Highmore
it's actually my birthday today
I'm 27 as of a couple of hours ago
Oh perfect
thank you happy birthday to me
does Freddie Highmore sing yes if I say
yes then I'll probably have to try and
attempt to sing so I'm gonna say no but
also that's the honest answer I don't
sing unless it's Taylor Swift does
Freddie Highmore have an accent no I
don't think I really do have an accent
this is the thing like American the
phrase that always gets me is American
saying lose your accent you lose your
accent really well as if American some
generic American accent is the accent
and anyone who doesn't speak in that way
has a weird accent but anyway this is
how I speak did Freddie Highmore
play both brothers in Spiderwick
Chronicles I think chronicles yes I
played twins which was great probably
goes slightly insane at the end of
shootings you just sit there
opposite someone who or opposite a
tennis ball and pretending that you're
sitting opposite yourself and having
conversations with yourself that's true
okay who is Freddie Highmore that's me
I'm Freddie Highmore I am him this is
the person is Freddie Highmore English
yes I am English I'm English and British
from the UK
you probably didn't need to ask that
question having heard me pronounce the
answer to the first one is Freddie
Highmore Arabic it's an odd idea isn't
it people type this into Google they're
like it's pretty high when English they
get confirmation but then they don't
believe it they're like but is he Arabic
but no I'm not Arabic I did study Arabic
I mean I I studied it for a couple of
years and then I never really managed to
practice it out in the Middle East
unfortunately and we'll have Cathedral
portal condom the slight pause is like
what does that mean is Freddie Highmore
the good doctor yes well I I play the
good doctor is Freddie Highmore related
to Hugh Grant I'm not related to you
grant so I guess the short answer is no
it would be nice to be related to Hugh
Grant
I'm sure where does Freddie Highmore
live now
well we filmed the good doctor in
Vancouver so I'm spending a lot of the
year in Canada but I'd still like to
think that London so even if I don't get
to go back as much as I'd like the
Pacific Northwest is is nothing like
London but Vancouver's a lovely City
yeah I like being there it's my home
away from home
where is Freddie Highmore from I'm from
London and I'm not sure there's really
anything else to say North London where
to meet Freddie Highmore I guess
here right now at an Arsenal game if you
end up visiting London and you might
catch me there we've got season tickets
so whenever I'm back in London you will
find me an Arsenal game and I will say
hello Freddie Highmore it's a bit weird
just saying your own name again and
again it's it feels very detached anyway
it doesn't feel like Freddie hi it
doesn't just doesn't feel like yourself
when you say your full name but anyway
onwards will Freddie Highmore win Golden
Globe I did not win the Golden Globe but
always lovely to be nominated who does
Freddie Highmore play in the Golden
Compass I was actually just the voice of
punter lineman or pontil ermine who does
Freddie Highmore look like clearly Hugh
Grant given our earlier question and
it's probably about it didn't think I
don't like anyone please tell me if I do
was Freddie Highmore in Harry Potter I
wasn't in Harry Potter I know I feel
like every young British actor made it
in but not me they didn't want me can
Freddie Highmore play instruments I
played the recorder when I was young and
I learned the guitar for a film as well
Fergus rush which was filmed here in New
York I learnt the guitar but I kind of
focused very specifically on the songs
that were in the film so I didn't have
much of a sort of repertoire to play
afterwards other than the same few songs
again and again and again but I will
have to take it up there's still time
thank you very much for googling me and
thank you for doing anyway and giving me
these wonderful questions to answer and
thanks for watching